[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
what's going on what's going on people
about 3 30 a little rolling start early
as we get people in
cat daddy what's going on brother yeah
we definitely need that price release
pre-orders all that good stuff
long live the king i see y'all waiting
for the king he'll be here yo let me
know how my levels are sounding
you know scrub nurse boy it's gonna be
messy in here today
you know the king is coming that's all
y'all know crazy if you do what's up man
yo um deaf singers in the building
addicts in the building we're gonna get
more people in the building
um do me a favor y'all talk talk to the
people
[Music]
who's ready for a 400
psvr2 to be released who's ready for it
a thousand vmps vr on your ps5 oh man
well you're dead singer what's up man
sounds good thank you scrub all right so
what we'll do is when we get live we'll
switch again
probably watch the twitch stream and um
see how the levels are because i think
their shows tend to be a bit
louder but we are chilling we're going
to wait for the king
and a couple others and then uh once
that thing gets close we will
switch you guys over see you in a bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
what's good old people we are live we
are out here pre-showing
everybody with the mic check the kings
and the building beats is here
let us know if again can't talk to the
people they been waiting for you man um
all i can say is uh they got you know
what you know what
today is a l if they don't do four
things
do we need first of all they gotta stand
up with the unit in the hands
[Music]
but you know you got a mock-up it's cool
just have something in your hands
um okay all right i want to see miles
more routes
yes okay i want to see miles morales
factual um i want to hear
and all this ties into the third thing
price
yes release date yes and pre-order time
what a question question what is a good
price that you chose
i don't care about the price i don't
give a [ __ ] about it so sorry sorry i
don't care about the price i don't care
about the price at all that that's not
an issue for me because
i'm losing but we're not talking about
from the standpoint we're talking about
it's going to be 550 500 um
okay that's all you know because they
have no need to wiggle a price
it's reasons behind that in my opinion
they don't have to meet microsoft
anywhere
that's a fact they don't have guys they
don't have to
that's why my my question was why the
the when i said we had the last iop when
i was talking to ryan i was like
you know why do you think the
apprehension so the vibe i'm hearing is
more about the
x price so we'll see what's up yeah and
and the last thing that i feel they have
to do
they have to be very clear with this bad
compact stuff
now i know that's a long shot i know
that
probably won't even happen all right um
but if they can just
be a little bit more clearer for a lot
of people because i have people really
questioning um how should they move like
turn down the twitch just a little bit
while we talk
about they don't they don't know they
don't know if they're gonna um
support it if they don't do backup
and in my opinion this is what i think
they mean when they say they they
uh cryptic stuff playstation 4 is safe
but then you got people that's like oh
you know what they were saying that the
playstation 1 and the 203
and i want to know if i can get rid of
my systems and what i said brother
i can't even give you a clear answer
because i i stopped playing those games
because in my opinion with them it was
always the next on to the next
right like we did with the pass on to
the next so when they started talking
back to pat
i was like really you guys so i don't
know but then ubisoft kind of
said no what is it uh anything about
playing station four or something like
that what was it uh forte
by the way forte gave me before it takes
in the building recently 2k
2 000 subs please support this man's
channel he is killing it out here
videos are amazing you know we joke on
him about eight or nine podcasts
but at the end of the day this is our
dude he's out here he's making
fantastic content so gaming for tays in
the building what's your thoughts man we
on the eve
of the highly anticipated place man
i just need this stuff to get it now so
people get at work and leave me the hell
around
that's what i need man and i'm wit and
the one thing i'm 100
we keen on is we need to find out about
how next generation is going to be
impacted by the stuff that we have now
all of these games and all of this stuff
that's going to carry over
this whole the top 100 games that's
going to be on your playstation 4
working on your ps5
you know what accessories are going to
work going forward we already know the
controllers will work but only on ps4
games but what about
all of these headsets and all of this
stuff that people bought what about
these
controllers that are 200 that people
paid money for
i just want to be able to tell people
like look man
microsoft for the last year has told me
that all your stuff gonna move forward
so it's been an easy position to tell
guests that going forward
but when it comes to playstation it's
like i don't know for him
god move forward if i had to put money
on it i would say it
is but i don't know because sony hasn't
came out and said anything
so i think that's one of the things for
just my
sanity i want them to come out and talk
about but outside of that
i really don't like you already he said
who let forte up on here
there's only one person in the community
that would say i didn't even have to
even know who said it
as soon as you said i said i looked at
the chat and i was like
if oh remember old school gi joe it's
tomax and zama you're out of brothers
psychopathically linked he's your
opponent right exactly
exactly that's right shout out to shout
out to my homeboy man
yeah you know
um the last thing is look i don't do do
i really
truly care about this price i'm like
king i'm getting the system regardless
but i'm trying to get as much as i can i
mean you gotta look
i don't want to pay a lot of money for
this system but to me it's funny
that they ain't said nothing like sony
don't have to wait for
anybody right because their system is
going to sell regardless at whatever
price point
i'm not saying this could be 700 or
anything like that
but if they put the if their system was
going to be 500
they could have put it out there already
hey how's it going guys here we go yeah
we're on the street right now is they're
not even going to say the place
uh the price or anything during this
event oh don't say that no
yeah i know no they must say this is
games look man this is this
show
ryan did say that we will start
pre-orders without a price
unfortunately what's going on
finish up because i want to get the rest
of the intros in before we got five
minutes
yeah no like the word on the street
right now is they're not even gonna have
this uh
the price or anything or even like the
release date announced during this event
um but they're gonna be releasing a blog
post right afterwards
ugh
here's the only thing about it though
which would make sense if they come out
they say oh this is about our
third-party games
this is about this we're not talking
about the console during this event
i don't know got to be here
shout out to hold on boom it's being
petty don't you're not even going to see
the
boom
let me get my man man i'm so happy that
he's doing better
physically you know what i'm saying this
is my guy right here mojo
blues brother how you doing brother i'm
doing good what up everybody what's up
yes sir yes we can hear you brother
being pop on the screen i'm not seeing
like a little
audio like i see on everybody else now
are you excited sir are you are you
anticipating that
i think this is going to be mostly about
the game but i do believe you will see
the console
and you will get the prize for the
release okay
and i'm rarely even believe they're
going to announce
uh three orders immediately after the
show
it's gonna be a short post show y'all if
that's the case
it's gonna be a short post show for
cognito as i
race to the local store right now i'm
studying right now if we don't get
release dates
and we don't get um the the the cost
this shows an l i don't care what they
show mojo
but that is what people want to see we
got some super chats we got yo first of
all shout out to stitch
6695 super chat keep dreaming on that
price
hashtag dance move ryan
guys shout out to my man matija novak
with the hrk
15. i don't know what that currency is
but say something so oh you put an emoji
salute thank you and then dirt oh wow
dirty swaggy
welcome to the realm what the the horns
in here crazy names
i like that you got that dirty swag
from perfect show hitting that like
button has no
yo that was dope that was dope i'll
respect that and last but not least
because we got 30 minutes
three minutes i gotta i'll get my man
then the legend
across the pawn my man that singer
what's going on sir
what's going on everyone hey is it going
good man good man get you back in the
room they telling me that
we need to get blaze in here to get your
counterpart that's what they say yeah i
don't know why blaze is in here
like i guess i tried i suggested it i
just suggested it yeah we always get
blaze no but i got
i think he got too much heat from the
last time
yeah he didn't get it playstation nation
he don't like the energy that happens
when he around me with the playstation
no the playstation guys don't like that
y'all friendly
that's nice they didn't go like when i'm
selling them that playstation for three
grand
oh my god we can't each and yo and i'm
gonna do like gym dance move you get
nothing in the box
you out here hustling the dreams i swear
to you playstation dudes i'm going to
get your pockets and have it in the
headlights
oh angelo geo man salute man follow us
happy to finally catch you fellas live
excited to see what we're getting this
will in the very least be interesting
oh yeah it's going to be lee somebody
said it best i am mike said
i'm here for two reasons either sony go
show out or kingo had the greatest show
of the generation so that that's that's
the vibes everybody's going on right
there
i guess before yeah before we start give
y'all some xbox stuff
um the pre-orders yes um if you're
buying at
if you're well i don't know what other
retailers are but what we're doing is
on the 22nd east coast hope stores open
at 11. pre-orders go live right at 11
o'clock on the 22nd
if you're central 10 o'clock if you're
if you're west coast 8 a.m
okay that's big so they're not they're
not doing the whole stagger thing
it's basically starting with east coast
going all the way to west coast so
sorry for the west coast people they got
to get up super early in the morning and
make sure they get those pre-orders in
but uh yeah eight o'clock in the morning
on the west coast if you want to get one
of
those
systems and it's only one per customer
even if you're trying to do
the opposite system like both versions
of the system got you j
force gave [ __ ] that's the chat sorry
got it good good good
now it's payback they get to play the
games at nine o'clock in the night
when the games come out at midnight you
can get up early
yeah that's true that's true get your
butt up j force game files from chat
doesn't matter if this is good or a bad
show you know playstation always wins
with this
media by damn okay what's the truth
don't start with just shaving them
playstation always wins
what about gamescom they came out but
mark's trying to put everybody to sleep
tell everybody again it's less powerful
oh my god yeah but they still won them i
mean i still heard people walking around
with
you know the way that they wrap around
the sound around your ears
and they say do you know mark's
certainly was telling you how to crack
and be cracking
i'm like man shut up that's it
and then oh wow game over brian 10 super
chat thank you guys for a great podcast
it helps me through these hard mumps
king and mario are the best oh thank you
matter of fact where is mario atkins
right wait
it's four o'clock it's four o'clock all
right oh why are they jumping right into
it
he did it sorry's on time oh my god
let me know how the levels are turn the
levels up for them louder y'all chat
there it is there's the console king
silence
i'm at the sony show and twitch go to
twitch go to twitter i don't
i'm not on twitch i do not add extra
stuff to my teams
i mean look at my pc sorry are you on
the platform
yeah yeah i'm on the special event
channel right now on
twitch you see things others that's not
the console
it started with a console with a silicon
graphics
again why would you stop
literally gave all my guys the rest of
the day off so i could see these taking
live
yo you were savage tony bryant dance jim
dick
wow y'all have a king messi i love this
they showed you everything we saw
already
systems controllers okay
oh here we go y'all let's get it now
wait 10 minutes oh the following contest
captured on the pc
emulating the place they should fight
king is on to something
now just to let y'all know i spoke the
gym dance move ryan this morning
i said stop putting that cap at the
bottom
i'm trying to hear this
i see a lack of social distancing here
i'm very
concerned here
oh shovel all right
this will be a bitter fight it looks
like a playstation 4
plus alcoholic ass is not going to be
happy there's only a dog no cats
we couldn't show this i'm trying to hear
this man
close your eyes i don't have any knees
get some ears
is this like final fantasy butcher yo
what's going on on the dog
is
[Applause]
come on
just like final fantasy dark souls now
yeah like final fantasy viii
they really mean stitch with the ten
dollars for the chat this is already a
straight now
this garbage
[Music]
i'm still trying to see something in
this trailer that makes me feel like i
can't play this on next box
when it does come out on it that's the
only time i'm gonna play it
let's get it
oh
[Music]
hot
playstation console exclusively also
available on pc
oh day and day
shout
microsoft keeps losing these jrpgs and
they keep playing i don't care he's on
steam
shut out the steam let's keep it real
let's get the real estate
hey hey 30 80's babe you gotta get a
chat
i know i my 3080 looking real good with
that yeah for real because it was
captured on the 3080
great playstation all right all
cinematic is about to see from this
point forward
is captured from playstation 5 system
shots fired let's go
yeah dev systems they're coming for you
they heard you talking to me he was
running your lips
let's go
wait did they say this is just cinematic
so they say there's no gameplay in this
there's going to be games
oh gosh i wasn't sure i missed that part
there we go
come on miles let's get it shout out
chess out okay so this is one off the
bucket list
let's go
[Music]
puerto rico said yo
so miles you heard what was going on
put the bodyguards in the chat that's in
the chat you see they repping she's been
a teacher my whole life
oh they go get that boy
someone running for mayor or something
yeah yeah somebody [ __ ] yeah
salsa salsa hip steps probably his mom
well you know i'm brian he's fine
we're excited to show you the first look
at gameplay from marvel spider-man miles
morales
our story picks up one year after the
events of the first week you can hear it
in the background is in danger
trouble brews while mao's mom rio
morales leads an election
on your rally roxanne and the
underground a high-tech criminal army
led by the tinkerer starts to break out
in this gameplay sequence
captured on playstation 5 hardware the
underground attacks roxon
sending the rally into chaos in a fight
that spills onto the braithwaite bridge
where the underground tries to steal
roxanne's experimental energy source
with the new form let's take a look
harlem boy hall i'm on the rise
let's not shoot each other all right
he is a good character
i think i see insomniac's game they're
going to take no-name villains and give
them a shot
i can get jiggy with this
well that was always getting jiggy with
then grab as much as you can carry
yo okay well we said definitely you take
her a little like a hundred
he does and his people look like me
why do i get the sneaking suspicion this
entire game is going to take place at
night
yeah because of the whole neon look yeah
yeah they better have more gameplay than
him just walking through a festival man
oh
this look crazy
this game play low key look better than
2018's gameplay
[Music]
oh my god don't front chat come on y'all
look at that regardless how good this
looks
still an expansion i mean it is what it
is but
you got to give it up got to give it up
though got to get on this look good
i told you this was one of my things on
my list so they did that
get the first one they ain't do the
first one they did the second one
miles was the second one oh
yeah i feel like this game is going to
be like uh like an arkham situation oh
it's all a one night you gotta do this
real quick
it definitely looks impressive
it looks better than that piece of [ __ ]
that one had 2018
no this is a fire bro this looks way
better than two thousand
let's get it let's get let's get let's
get it i like the particle effect
i like what's going on i like the
lighting something they can cross
you saw that yes the lighting looks good
i can stop this yeah this looks this is
way better classic vintage kind of
iconic spiderman
[Music]
did you see the lumens
[Music]
gta 7 we just give it six
couple anime
welcome to the solstice
i feel like they're gonna do december i
don't know
they're all saying where's peter oh it's
the harry potter hundreds of people game
it's the harry potter game yes finally
harry potter oh it's a uk stand up let's
go
together no i love harry potter i want
to see what
that's common bonds
i gotta give mad respect to them for
actually starting on time
that's a big deal
all right what's the when is this taking
place though
late 1800s yeah but i meant in the
timeline
harry potter uh prior to voldemort
and your riddle stuff in this castle
it's the pre-crew prequel
you don't got a headset or something i
do but you're talking over my head
go into game barry
[Music]
this is for the young folks
this is the first big harry potter game
forever your potential
[Music]
the reason why
[Music]
but what form will it take
[Music]
and everything
[Music]
to do doubles bang avalanche 2021
okay let's see what we got we'll see
so far strong start
what was the first exclusivity final
fantasy
i'm a little surprised no deal with
hogwarts
hi everyone dan johnson creative
director
one of our goals as developers is to
bring all the life
unlike anything you've ever experienced
and the playstation 5
is making that happen with the power of
the new console we've been able to see
what kind of
bsd
in the middle of one of the most
dangerous times the world has ever known
but in true black ops style nothing is
as it seems
take a look
let's pat out this runtime all right
come on this is big
anchor call it i ain't really trying to
see call of duty ankles
arrived in turkey a few hours ago we
didn't saw it four times already world
is ready
i think treyarch's tired of trying to
lift that division up right now
let's get him put 20 in the chat that
like button
okay some gameplay
right now do you guys think they're
going to do a deal with call of duty do
you think it's going to happen to
marketing
yeah yeah we don't care about the
marketing we're talking about like an
exclusive delivery
that's not happening oh you mean like
fully
no no no no not fully no no no no i mean
like oh yeah
you met pax dlc one year earlier or
something
i could see somebody doing that i could
see sony doing that man
i bet they want to but did but did that
happen from modern warfare that's called
a duty
release we know that they spent money on
a lot of big stuff
exclusive so the call of duty fits the
bill
might have truck that was surprised by
the hogwarts one he said
zombies are exclusive if they do that
you crazy
they will cut out a huge portion of
their money i remember they've done that
before
they got a whole section of the remember
they did that like two years ago
i don't i don't play it man i don't buy
this stuff
[Music]
knees
oh
rc has been in call of duty black ops
that's what black ops
play without limits roll
i up know about that xbox i don't know
how that car is out running jeeps i know
right just let it go
man this is a blockbuster film if you
went to the blockbuster film
get it it's not done
it
there are many more twists and turns
along the way as you begin to unravel
the truth and we can't wait for you to
play it soon
in addition to the story campaign cold
war features the next generation of
multiplayer online combat
and an all-new awesome design you sure
know how to juice up today's
special honor to announce without my
friends at treyarch
that the playstation community doesn't
have to wait to play multiplayer oh
starting this friday playstation players
will be able to play the multiplayer
alphabet exclusively
on playstation 4. and for those of you
that are watching at home on your ps4
you can preliminal
shut up
[Music]
content for a particular console needs
to be checked games are for the gamers
not the console
frauds and shame on them don't be hating
if you ain't scurly
none of this stuff sony knows how to do
a digital event i will say that much
they know how to do this
[Music]
yeah rainbow six quarantine
captain yo you stupid let's go
quarantine yo they coming out with head
bangers body head bangers on you king
bang bang bang
i wrote
twitch uh thing said uh pub g76
it was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark
this is the real gameplay yeah i was
like did this
you can't say that
i'm excited
yes it is coming no warrior did tweet it
it is coming to playstation 4. so why
would i buy it on playstation
playstation
all right so right there they basically
just ended the reason why everybody said
you know
and they just ended the reason they just
entered the reason people said it was no
way to play do that
it's just an exhibition hey bro
this is what to get done oh you can only
play it on ps5
i thought it was exclusive
[Music]
that bethesda's deal with death loop it
getting delayed does not count towards
the exclusivity time
[Music]
they're talking about like if the deal
was for a year exactly if it got delayed
it does not stop the time was still
going cyber still goes
let's go supposedly
let's talk about the real news
one final fantasy 16 xv
smitty smith
yeah we kind of figured it out
spider-man ps4
the bridge is over the bridge is over
whatever yo he's
3.99 for what give y'all
your knee please put your
knees in the box
[Music]
oh no yes that's a joke that's a joke
john is zombie it's all
playstation 5 is actually coming out
next year
or even in december that would make
sense then it is strange because
we all thought it was a it was a
gangster move to make it playstation 5
only
to force them but if they put in it is
interesting why they would put it
[Music]
people are nearly on twitter asking if
their ps4 version
upgrades to the ps5 version and i don't
get these people man
like you were willing to spend oh yeah
but but xbox one is holding yo yo you
don't
get a playstation 5 so what are you
worrying about
upgrading no don't you remember
insomniac told everybody there was no
remaster it's a standalone game
game
that's how the whole thing goes that's
how it's done it's gone
[Music]
[Music]
though they could bounce back with that
yeah yeah about your price because it's
going to be
three grand for you
see me on these guys if this thing if
this thing gets delayed till next year
it's going to be 3.99 hey you know
[Music]
they got the
[Music]
dude this is it this is the best show
everybody
it's coming out this year that's why he
said they're laughing
already why are you showing dmc
live again maximus it's coming out this
year
it's coming out this year that's why
they're showing it now you know they
need something
novak celia said i need knees i told
people it was a glorified dlc
gaming addict had my back oh
this is how you lose a generation
guys guys we got nine minutes left that
was like 40 minutes
late but we're getting close miles
morales could only
[Music]
finds himself fresh
the obstacles
the show itself is good no no the show
itself that is showing us is great but
there's always little stuff
behind the scenes that they're hiding
swipe left like they're on yo
yo yo what if all the games play these
sort of miles before the playstation pro
all right
well you'll purchase again in 2022.
oh this ain't looking good
this looks like portal bridge
constructor oh god
this is how the bushes happened to you
this five nights at freddy's or
something like crazy oh
kate king this is five nights at
freddy's this is five nights at freddy's
they're getting old people
what is this what did they do are they
sabotaging this show right now or they
[Music]
spreading money all around we have five
minutes
five minutes five minutes it's gonna
take him five minutes
all
this is how it ended i swear this game
comes to playstation 4 2.
sony went to the strip club with a bunch
of ones
yo you stupid [ __ ] don't let it don't
let it like
they making it rain with quarters and
nickels yeah that's why the girls have
umbrellas
oh sony out here giving concussions
you guys got fees
please that's how slow the playstation
going right now
look like playstation 4 all over again
it does it doesn't look anything special
i'm really going in have you not been
watching the show
i beat on this oh my god
hold up uh release dates so
death lube is coming out quarter two of
2021.
um yeah so don't tell me um demon tells
if it's on that i want to see
yeah it doesn't turn out super chat
ponies buying a new console for old
games you got savage
continue continue now that that's all i
got so far
right now they're [ __ ] interrupted to
say one damn police they stopped yeah it
was only gonna take 10 seconds oh
to buy old games again gamer by choice
followers y'all are her lashes
hilariously messy
they get it to me they came for me dude
name all in their mouth now how your
mouth tastes
it tastes pretty salty man it takes no
no the only way in terms of in terms of
a launch this is a very weak
launch right now but if they come out
and they cut
and they show the right price there this
dude
i gotta complain look this dude look
dirty yo let me ask
a question i don't care what price they
come out with if they only have 10
consoles
that's a boss in there that's a boss in
there fellas yeah it is
they don't it doesn't matter about the
price man you keep talking price
they're not gonna be cheating the price
is definitely important stop it
no it's not you know what yeah it is
[Music]
just
i know we know this is not gonna happen
we know that's not gonna happen but if
they did get they came out and they said
oh yeah did auditions 300.
if you'll be like screw the s
you can't get it i'm not gonna watch on
this [ __ ] right now man
it looks good i mean it looks nice is
the audio cut out
no that's just really quiet
okay just just make a shirt cause i was
like you could be watching this on a
playstation
do you know what to do how would you
know
what what
yeah well they're not giving no price
today yeah because we're we got one
minute left
so we got to get over a little bit
longer yo that price really might be in
a blog post
oh god sorry somebody smith i missed
your super chat look man
if they i'll go ahead with the super
chat looking for it damn it
i was gonna say but maybe they put the
price in the blog chat just so they
don't have the ssd so fast so they
pulled the fast one
i got you i got you bro sorry about that
all right one minute what's gotta be the
price right we gotta have
hopefully price or a teaser
no did that demonstrate
nope nope no no release date no day
oh it's ending fortnite this is
fortnight yeah
before night stuff oh my god i swear to
god
we got it nobody got ghost is
it's like what a three or four year old
game now though like is this really
worthy of being the biggest
okay maybe the emerging playstation plus
playstation now
maybe maybe no value proposition they're
they're just axing it we can't beat game
pass we're getting rid of it
let's see well that's playstation now
actually
a new playstation plus benefit
[Applause]
this is captured on playstation 5.
bloodborne was part of that that's
interesting
oh this is this is the backwards
compatibility thing this is
going to be
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what i play on playstation 5 old
games right
hundred games that's probably yes
these are the ones now questions do you
have to buy them or they could be free
probably gonna buy them but we gotta pay
they started a whole new category oh you
know when they start categories your
cash gotta go
so
yeah why is this not enhanced and why
wait wait wait wait it look look for
last was part two on here
if they don't have it at launch that's
gonna be concerning
i know what i'm talking about you you're
gonna buy it again i didn't know that's
all i'm saying
it wasn't there i don't have it wait a
second
wait enjoy a selection of great
playstation for access
download games and start playing this
this is how they're going to say it from
now on this is they're going to say oh
it's in the collection
we don't have backwards compatibly we
have playstation plus collections
this is exactly what a hip hop was
talking about they're doing it
crazy different than anybody
here's the price hit pop where's it
let's go lead
it's the price right here let's go this
the price
shut up i'm trying to hear this
this is the mic drop let's go
that's the end of the stream that's what
it was that
[Music]
all right oh there's the sisters laying
on the side on the side let you know
they leave it on the side and walk away
[Music]
please okay stop the turn so we can see
the price
get that price number on that we already
know the system looked like
we don't know what the back of it looked
like but we don't know what it looked
like
because that's the cgi render was that
the back of it right there oh they found
each other's lips in the back
here we go numbers come on show the
price
they're five and four hundred four five
and four
november what happened tonight november
12th
november 12th november 19th rest of the
world okay so that's a big all right
it's your passion as fans of gaming that
drives us to deliver a truly new
generation of experiences on ps5
from everyone at playstation we
appreciate your continued support
and we look forward to you getting your
hands on ps5
very soon to close let me leave you
with one more quick start of war he
looks like he's on a rough weekend there
we go
he got a rough weekend man is that god
what is that foreign
[Music]
yeah here we go oh ragnarok
let's go did they literally did they
literally just listen to what people
told them to do on twitter
is that all they did they just listened
to what people told them to do on
twitter
yo shitty sweetie say that three years
it's coming
dude oh quick
oh no that's good that's big all right
they ready
good that's the best of knowledge
[Music]
let's be real but i expected like
twenty twenty two twenty four i expected
them not to put a year on it
you know this yeah but it is big that is
coming back from three orders
but that's what they can easily put a
date on it and delay it later
they can put a date on it now to get
people excited
the latest game later the geeky dirt say
god of war 2 before halo laugh out loud
that's crazy now we can see two
different ragnaroks
but people the same thing about
spiderman before right now
this is crazy let's get tip
yeah this is this is not a good launch
let's go with that
let's go with the joke stop the mess
let's get to the pen
that's all that's all you got to see the
nice little
well the fact
like i said no day and date people
people don't realize this pandemic a lot
of this stuff
yo slow-mo said rap will be interested
today
oh brian's gonna be real interesting
tonight bro
be on fire tonight so so
give us a preview of what you're
standing
look man i just want to know what these
people gonna buy
on day one since the reason oh the
reason i was gonna buy a plate because
spider-man could only be done on the ps5
that's why we heard a lot i want to know
i want to know
i want to know why are you going on the
ratchet that's a good point emperor
yeah well they're trying to show things
that people
didn't know about like they didn't show
horizon either all right
go back to the google hangout launch a
window at all
okay some neck is not putting out uh two
two games around and saying no no
ratchet is coming out next year they
space yeah raptors coming out next year
i never thought that was coming out
early
oh so everybody they got to stop capping
like
this is really getting out of control it
was
for me my whole thing is spiderman like
like i
understand what people keep saying that
it's not a dlt because they
they they want them to feel like it's
something different but for me
if they turn around and bring spider-man
out that fast
that means they're using a lot of the
stuff they already had with the original
spider-man
and they just upped everything to make
it look better they did some control
changes and made the game more fluid put
it on the new system
i could see them actually doing that but
it's like they showed
so much a ratchet and clank for me to
feel like that was a brand new game
you would think ratchet and clank is the
game they put out first and spider-man
came out later
because they would need more time to do
that you you know what's interesting
brand new game you know what's
interesting though that i want to bring
up come on they just put that goblin
look like a brand new game what forte
was what's that when you saw a ratchet
you thought it looked like
no no no no i'm just saying ratchet and
clank is a game that they haven't
like spider-man came out in 2018 when
did ratchet and clay come out like 2017
yeah the launch yeah yeah so that's what
i'm saying so ratchet and claim
it's been longer since that's been a
development and they
showed more of it so i was thinking they
should have ratchet they clank be the
game that launches you know
day one with the system and spider-man
be the game that comes out later on
because they can take more time to
actually polish and make it even better
for the next generation
but the fact that they were racing out
to get spider-man out first day one
is the reason why a lot of people felt
like dude you couldn't have done that
much stuff to the game over the course
of a year
and a half to basically make it that big
of a difference of the game
you know what you know what's crazy
you know what's crazy it's it's the the
way they're releasing stuff they're
releasing
in on november 12th they're releasing in
the united states japan canada
i know what they're doing australia new
zealand and south korea
and then like a week later they're
releasing the rest of the world so like
does the uk don't get that you know why
they're doing so
so i'll tell you why they're doing this
and like i said this is if anybody can
say hyperbole or anything
yeah micros where's microsoft's biggest
region
nice america north america
most of those most of those countries
you see in there are in north america
where is microsoft's second strongest
australia
they want to get microsoft is already
releasing first
they don't want microsoft to get a huge
lead in these
different areas and those territories
because think about it once a person
if you if casual people start buying
systems day one
there's no reason for them to buy
another system because 97 of the games
are on both systems
they don't if they don't care about the
spider-mans and the
last of us and god awards they don't
have to go out to buy another system
so they're trying to meet microsoft head
on in the territories that they know
microsoft is strongest at and that's why
they're dedicating so many systems to
those areas
they're saying we're still going to win
in the territories like japan
we're going to still win in uk because
check it uk
is their biggest market they all people
don't realize that microsoft
out is outsold in the uk almost like one
eight to one
in the uk but in america it's like two
it's like literally one to two they're
only losing by four or five million
systems here in the us
so they want to say hey we don't want to
lose in ameri because what happens if we
lose here
will happen what happened last
generation microsoft won
like six to one in america but they lost
heavily everywhere else right but look
what the numbers say
86 million sold for xbox 87 89 million
sold for playstation
they're saying we don't want to have a
repeat of that so we're going to fight
where microsoft is going to be the
strongest
and save all our stuff later on which is
a week later
it's a smart move it's just basically
going to alienate a lot of people in
other countries saying
i know a lot of people that's going to
be really upset by that like yeah
because they're basically saying that
america is more important right now
than the rest of the world and let's be
for real when it comes to the fight
against
microsoft america is more important
because
that's where they're going to sell the
most systems at no matter what
they just feel like we're going to sell
these systems and they're basically just
assuming
that the uk is going to buy playstations
no matter what over xbox
no figures let me get these super chats
and then we can actually elemental
appeal files to chat did you
see all that bad clipping in the game
playing wow
76 uh will the playstation 5 fit inside
my stand
oh tony bryant oh it's going to be your
stand all day
on death loop and not one second of
godfall
perfect shogun two dozen anchorman they
gonna stop doubting me
fam i guess y'all know oh no on the show
uh on the show on monday that we had he
he was very adamant about the 500 400
dollar prices
drunk i thought that was going to be 50
bucks so two dollar super chat
playstation 5 will not win japan
because of the size of the console
dj birdo dose spiderman miles morales
going to playstation 4 as well laugh out
loud smiley face
and all right so let's get to it man um
anchor because i know your time's
limited
let me get you in and then we get mojo
right at this let's get that's what you
got
all right so overall general uh thoughts
about the show
yeah um i think it was a great show like
the first half was like
one after another like bam bam bam bam i
was like yeah this is great
and then it's like they just tanked it
at the end like
look what tank like
uh when they started showing off uh i
already forgot what the game of game was
already
that's how hot the show was for you
right like i mean i i personally don't
care about demon souls
so i mean i guess for some people that
might have salvaged a little bit of it
but like don't care about odd world the
fact fortnight's even being shown here
is
dumb odd choices yes i mean
i get you want to let nope let people
know that oh fortnite's gonna be on ps5
don't question it so all the
all the young kids gonna say oh i want
to play fortnite on playstation 5. why
would they
not think it wouldn't be because these
are these are
idiotic kids who don't know any better i
guess so
and also remember they just got their
fortnite pulled away from their uh
breaking news what's up uh spider-man
models
was just announced for 11 12 united
states and 11
19 everywhere else so it is launch yeah
it is going to be like oh that's great
that's okay that's good that's big
that's big
we're releasing the game on the ps4 as
well
that's huge that's right
the only thing about it though at least
with this particular one so the price
point is kind of like okay
expected they're playing it safe they're
not doing this deep dive stuff that
everybody was hoping they were going to
do like oh yeah just undercut
but my big question about this is that
this this launch is fairly
weak i don't care what anybody says this
launch is weak
it's on playstation 4. there's no reason
i mean it's the same thing people said
when when we thought halo was coming out
oh it's it's on the xbox so like why
does it matter
but that's the same thing like okay so
oh halo's going to be holding
it's going to be helpful
the big thing i'm concerned about is
because this is a straight-up example of
insomniac
lying they said no remaster
not coming this is completely standalone
this confirms what everybody thought
and now the perception is gone for this
scheme
it's not what people thought let me get
you real quick man we got 505 people
definitely at that likelihood
oh god still rocking with us
let's let's let's get those likes up now
like for those likes all right so
it's official anchorman they did come
out and say
like it was not a remaster what was the
verbiage
so what they said originally because
everyone was saying oh is this just
expanded dlc
uh they said no standalone game no
remaster
yeah they answered they put out in the
tweets and everybody's turning to the
miles thing
yeah but this is an example of either
this is an example of lying
as opposed to corporate speak they are
very particular and that's what we're
learning here too
they didn't show any of this now they
also here too
this is a very different thing as you
saw here they were claiming things were
exclusive not console launch exclusive
on here
we're finding out after the show right
that not all this is true
i think that that's my that's my biggest
issue with it is that they're claiming
stuff on the show
where people are going to see it and
they have enough room for a little
caveat to be added like oh
on pc or whatever but we're finding
about all this extra stuff
right behind the scenes like on here you
would have no idea it wasn't coming to
playstation 4
that's a good point that's a fact no
actually that's a very good point that's
a really good point no that you're right
i mean i get let's get mojo so
mojo brother you know shows that we got
it down it showcased the
the arrival we got all that good stuff
like where are you at how do you feel
about this showcase
the show was just it was awful i didn't
see all those
that people were talking about dlc
it's a five hour game five hour deal
three miles
no come on that's your big launch title
everything else was old games remasters
come on they they're hurting that launch
i'm just saying
a good thing they did get that all
digital one at 400
but right here's the thing the majority
playstation owner still preferred this
they buy four consoles they won't disc i
just
i got a feeling uh it's not that's not
going to go over well i have to pay
extra hundred dollars for that disk
drive it's only uh
i'll show you that's 50 only about eight
dollars for sony makes their own blu-ray
4k drive so so so my question i'm sorry
i gotta get continue mojo i better go
100 bucks more that's they're ripping
off people big time
but the show i didn't care for it even
resident evil 8 did not look good to me
he had to go uh jenkins stuff towards
the middle of it
right final fantasy didn't impress you
either
no i'm not i'm not he's like about
you know what when they screwed us from
final fantasy all right some more
breaking news
what is a long shower for the ps5 that's
big
souls and miles at launch so no you mean
just demon souls
same thing right i forgot about that def
but anyway continue mode
on ps5
[Music]
for a limited time also available on pc
show me that like link oh show me that
yeah send us a second
please please show that to us please
maximum i got you okay how should i send
it to you
on twitter put it on twitter
because you know on the rail i'm not if
demon souls is on pc
i ain't getting a playstation it's all
gone i'll just make a post and tag you
in it
yeah please please do because 3080s will
be ringing
in the street
you know you team 3080 now
i wasn't buying the game anyway if
that's the case and
demon souls isn't even a true exclusive
oh man the challenge is saying demon
souls to pc
confirmed we know that much
not available on other consoles for a
limited time also available on pc it's
not a l it's just it's a
it's an l that's an emotion no it's an l
for a base that's emotional about those
things right somebody check on
christopher hart
the living flame two dollars just
announced playstation got no games
so uh my buddy j main yeah my buddy j
main he was
he is so distraught now like he just
said um
so it's like liter this is literally an
uh a play in just two acts
one tweet two minutes ago demon souls
playstation 5 launch title let's go
playstation 5 confirmed it says then
then like one minute later wait demon
souls is coming to pc
you know if you gotta talk about anyway
mojo finish up y'all i need something
let me you guys continue why i continue
being messy i'll be right back all right
guys you're gonna be messy but i gotta
speak to mojos get his final thoughts
on price and then was there anything
that
did excite you about what what you saw
as much as the dlc kind of irks me
spiderman looked amazing yeah thank you
okay
nice i got no problem with that in that
launch because that's that's the savior
yeah facts everything else i mean demon
says come on who hasn't played dingy
how old is that come on i'm acting like
we're excited
stop actually i'm being excited cog
that's all i feel like listening
the price i'm not happy with 500 like i
said for the disk drive if you're gonna
sell one for 400
the most that one to me is 4k right you
know what though
and i i i'm with you on that but i i
think the reason 399 is the price they
had to go with
50 isn't enough for you to make somebody
decide between a disc and a disc drive
it's like it's like if i see a system
for 400 for 450
i'm like for 50 more i can get i'd
rather just have the disc drive
you got to make it a substantial
difference in price for people to say
i'm willing to give up the disk drive
right right you know and i think and i'm
with you
because i'm buying the physical copy
anyway because i want the disk drive
because i have
um uhd 4k blu-rays i want it for that
but they have to entice you by more than
50 bucks and 50 bucks ain't enough to
move me off that square
they're looking at it like we can make
more money off of digital purchases
by people buying this 399 system so
we'll make that money back
so if you want the physical one
unfortunately you got to spend that
50 that 100 difference but i'm with you
because i feel the same
exact way all right hold up spinning
smith following super chat playstation
fanboy games will not be day in day on
pc oh my god
let's let's take a moment of silence oh
lord
the amount of people that said they
they're they're only doing a couple
games king i thought they were only
doing a couple games on pc kings
well what do they say with pc sorry i
missed a little spot
it was just horizon horizon's the only
thing going that's all that's going
that is all that's going and now demon
slows all right
he's going day and day and i look they
only in the ip
king before you jump get your balls off
let me just get it they just don't own
them
make a lost seven five dollars thanks
for the stream can't wait to order the
pre-order the series x
please tell
all right no doubt mojo that was it so i
i got you bulge for the most part right
yeah yeah okay cool i just want to make
sure you okay cool um
death singer and addict now let's get
let's get deaf man um
where yeah bro
so jesus what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
buy a ps4
for like a hundred and then i'm gonna
play my persona five
and play my miles morales and then just
play everything else on pc and i'll see
you in 2021.
oh my god that's the cheapest option for
me because evidently
what do i need one for i mean i could
play persona 5 on my ps4
i could play miles morales on the ps4
fantasy final fantasy didn't move you
sir you're a final fantasy fan final
fantasy looked good but it's on pc
i'm going to play it on my pc yeah you
know it goes
so i mean demon souls i'll play that on
pc
godfall pc i mean bugs next okay
so i mean this you know i'll just buy a
ps4 for a hundred and
just call it a good day question yes is
who owns the iep for demon souls
obviously just did that what's the name
sony owns it they did it
yoshida said sony dropped the ball when
it passed the publishing demon souls in
north america and europe atlas and namco
picked up the slack with the latter
publishing from from software spiritual
success or dark souls
sony still owns the rights to
demonstrates intellectual property
so according to google they own the ip
they just don't own the publishing
rights right so this is sony's excuse
for publishing a game on xbox well when
they made a name
plus uh sony studio that lets you know
what was going to go down anyways
you know let's see microsoft did it too
long time ago but
well that was with minecraft and that
was just that was just minecraft it was
already about the name of the studio
when you change the name of the studios
you do it for a reason
please invite jw mooch and crap on just
so they can get to business
playstation exclusives on pc day and
date i'm dead
let me be real with you jd gamers they
ain't coming on the show
salute to them oh it's true they stayed
away from the show
to them kicked them two dollars i'm
tight
they removed the card reader what what
card reader oh you talk about the joke
you gotta wait until you activate it def
last question um
there's anything that excited you for
the future
or something to get a playstation 5.
is there any reason why um you know
anything to excite you for the future
to get a playstation 5. persona 6.
okay so you're just waiting for that
announcement then you win yeah like at
the other games
i the types of games i play god of war
on horizon
oh breaking news pre-orders available
tomorrow
really i'm good i ain't got to go oh i
gotta rush okay
okay nice all right cool add it but yeah
i'm sorry death sorry i finished i'm
sorry
yeah the price is price it's all right
but i mean it's it's
you know this for me there's no point
again
so right now you can wait you're in a
holding okay it's not another you sell
more okay
lord addict uh she's very vocal very
messy what's up man
this whole show all right so the price
is where i expected it to be
um the fact that you know they opened
the show
good wrong like i thought man i i was
sitting i was looking outside on you
king i said i don't know about it right
now man and then
and then they dropped the ball when did
they not only
did they drop the ball they deflated
that [ __ ]
it's like when i saw the special edition
dmc
i lost it oh that made me so like i was
like
you are not trying to say yo we got we
got devil may cry though
like we had it i thought they would have
won you over you're such a demon souls
fan like i thought loud like they got
you
they won the pieces they did have me
they did have me until about 10 minutes
ago
then they didn't happen because it's on
pc
like like let's be real that's what i'm
talking about yeah you and i have the
same page where it's literally
then the show it looks great look
there's all the stuff afterwards
that is the fine print of it i tried to
be a pc only gamer
and steve said steam and bungie and
people like that not having anti-cheats
in every game
they said this isn't the life for you
adam you need to go to a console for
every for something
so you know what i listened to steve i
said you know what steve you you're
right you're right
let me let me go over here back to xbox
and you know i i'll mingle with you man
i'll come over on the weekends man i'll
come over the weekends
so so you know now i i got i got the
perfect thing
i got my my xbox series x
and i got my place i got my playstation
pc
so you know what what i wanted my
playstation
we really did it when i want to play my
playstation
i got this 1080 ti that you're on your
boys
that your boy game before takes kindly
sold to me at a cheap price
and then and then you know what else i
had i got that series x i could play
everything else with
and when i don't feel like dealing with
the cheating guess what i'm gonna go
to the series x so let me ask you this
again sir
the fact that these games are coming to
pc is kind of
a death nail for you as far as rushing
you to not get a playstation fire
it's not that it's a death i will get a
playstation that's because god of war is
most likely not coming and day right but
21 though oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait what
no we're saying it's 20-22 let's be real
here come on
it's not 20-21 i'm just telling you what
they told me
i can't repeat what they say dates and
then they always move them man
but can we take this game hey hey hey
what what um so yeah
i i gotta go but one last thing yes
please other people caught on too to the
fact that
uh insomniac lied uh they have they
caught tweets where they
said it's only coming exclusively to
playstation five i remember those tweets
though not anywhere else
yeah they they yeah they're gonna get
involved ryan was like make it happen
no no gepetto
uh finish with squirreling dead hold on
let me get squirrely there 82
uh no card reader i'll use it'll use the
tap feature
iron mike fine oh damn it flew up i am
mike follow super chat attic stop what
you doing
and call in on a wellness check on jack
move why we gotta do that well
yeah i do and let me get my phone oh my
god smitty smith two dollar super chat
special edition devil may cry who mans
is this
the dj birdo dose follow subject king
did you find it funny
playstation 5 pre-order starts tomorrow
yet they didn't show us a
physical system only a rendering what
are they hiding
oh i'm gonna go into that on my part all
right cool gt swat
finger two dozen chat miles miles
portable by morales on playstation four
john b two dollars with chad portales
well port talis oh i got it i got poor i
gotcha
okay i'll see that good good catchphrase
i missed that right there
john b two dollar super chat phil is
laughing same price as xbox with less
power
okay now at it get your final balls off
as to
your whole look at the end of the day if
you're a playstation gamer a sole
playstation game like the jack moods i'm
not gonna say jw because he owns
everything we ain't gonna go into that
though right
but you know at the end of the day this
is for good for you
you know regardless if it comes to pc it
doesn't matter to you because you only
going to get the playstation but for
people like me
i'm going to get a playstation
eventually because some of these games
are not going to be coming to pc day one
i'm not waiting two
a year two years or whatever i'm not
hold on lord to gamer.net
like he said macho y'all capped for
getting series x day one
when y'all all got a pc but all of a
sudden playstation 4 got console
exclusives going to pc it's a problem
now i got i got it
i got it oh it ain't a problem
no there's a problem for every
individual that was running out here
talking about playstation
exclusives is so valuable that they
won't be someplace else because it
devalues the content
yo i told y'all before if you're going
to stand on a square stand
on it yeah see what it is
but the reality is there's a there's a
big group
that said you know what i'm saying like
that would devalue
the an xbox exclusive with the minute
they here come into pc
and and they would say like sony would
never do that right that was that was
the that was the talk at the time
so now we're seeing him sean
that's right you're right sean we're
just talking about those
people you know what i'm saying
they're still gonna sell me a
playstation right but right now we talk
about day one obviously you and king you
can go buy like eight of them you're
gonna buy one like selling them all
yeah so you know at the end of the day
you know you guys are gonna get you guys
are gonna invest into a brand because
cognito told me he want to compare so
that's cool you going he won't compare
but it's like at the end of the day i
have a pc that i could play hold on hold
on hold on we got the legend in here
the man with a million randolph or 19.
surprise
i told you you did i told you cognito
that miles would be on the playstation
ran down inside of man he's always
getting so
hey but so at the end of the day you
know i'm going to buy
a a playstation but what what i want to
focus on is like day one
like they got nothing if you have a pc
they really got nothing for you like
they really don't like let's be real
here
now if you want to upgrade because it's
the nice new tech and you want that
that giant monitor or whatever whatever
you want to say
shape is if you want that beside you get
it because but here's the problem bro he
said we knew play yeah but we
know it but you gotta understand the
base unfortunately the sony base
has been fighting us so long and saying
that these things will happen so to them
this is gonna be a shocker this is gonna
hurt a lot of people who are emotionally
tied to a console exclusive
they're gonna stay gonna feel betrayed
and i'm not gonna name their names but
we've had people on
that have said yo if they put their
stuff on pc i'm gonna feel away this is
hardcore sony go so
that's the majority of the guys that are
still emotionally tied to
this not having a game on pc thing
that's all we talk about sorry look at
the end of the day
these games that you're seeing they're
coming day and date to pc
don't be twisted their actual first
parties might not come day and day
but i guarantee you it's gonna be a
moment where you're gonna they're gonna
be six months apart that's all
right six months they're gonna be
popping on steaming at the game store
there's money to be made
if you guys want to go i'm not gonna
tell you what to do go out there and get
that playstation you know
you don't even need guns these days you
can get that to block your little wayne
couldn't go to that all right
i don't i don't promote violence
i got a dip oh okay brother later
yeah thank you very much thank you
brother
they're showing you that you know we got
god of war for you in 2022
you know we got horizon for you in 2021
and you know that's still a reason to
get a playstation but to me
there's not a reason to get a
playstation day one because demon souls
if i didn't have a pc there would be a
reason how did i tell you guys multiple
times yeah you did
give me demon souls i'm buying a
playstation if they give me demon souls
i'm buying a playstation okay well they
gave me demon souls
but they're like look you can go in this
door over here you don't need to go in
the water
you don't need to go in the 400 wall
door you can go in this
this sixty dollar door to the right like
stay messy vipe of xt
with the final canadian i thought sony
believed in generations
spider-man miles morales on playstation
4. when does the next generation start
yeah oh come on oh my god ksrt 5
super chat both don't have much for you
at launch but this is an xbox favor
because microsoft is playing a different
game
who asked nvidia about their exclusive
yeah
frame rate frame rate
okay so i see people saying no demons so
you know we're gonna say some people's
names because they're friends of the
realm but
you gotta get caught up man uh you know
i'm looking on on twitter real quick uh
luca says demon souls not being an
exclusive is a mistake
on their end not for us because i'm
winning either way
agreed here's mooch lord mood shout out
to lord booch
so sony owns the demon souls ip uh you
know
in parentheses other consoles might meet
ps4
at a later date so so you need to tell
me they're gonna have a ps4
they're gonna release it to old [ __ ] oh
uh australian twenty dollars guys i
missed the show did they say the price
yes four hundred dollars digital five
hundred dollars for the physical
so lord king are you ready
are we ready get the bars off ken yeah
okay all right so what i thought about
the show
i get a show or two oh god damn i'm
waiting
cognito i want you to click king's name
so we see him and then only from this
ring
i'm gonna give it a two mm-hmm let me
give it a two
because i see the level of hypocrisy
which you do
i see i see it it's at his height
and i crush you dudes on a daily
y'all thought i was going to pull up and
get served
like every time we do these shows y'all
like king gonna get served today to
elves is gonna be handed out
we gonna get his knees we out and then
y'all like crickets in the bushes
quiet and i tell you before the show
starts and after the show ends
no matter what i'm be victorious why
because i picked the winning horse i can
look at my dude in the eye
and know exactly what he's going to
deliver because he's been delivering
with the same energy
from day one to now so now it's about
you
it's all about you tcl dudes
y'all was telling me before halo was
holding back
the series x because it was on the
action coding back
we want to see the full fidelity baby
baby so y'all was telling me
yo king stop capping is not dlc
you know i'm telling you it's a
standalone game yeah
station 5 baby
so i told y'all
exactly what it was then they had the
nerve to run out there with the weakest
game
pass hustle they they yo they shoveled
in a whole bunch of old whack games
oh oh oh what was those those was your
dollar bangers right those was the ones
that y'all have for the 1999
uh a playstation hits so they got
all the hits together got a list of hits
it was like this is the playstation 5
plus collection
y'all played the same way it looked
before no enhancements
the same exact stutters when you save
exact stutter
and you dudes is lining up
there's absolutely zero reason to buy
that wax station
oh man zero reason
why miles you can stay put with the tcl
or your playstation pro and play it day
and day
right but there's no reason there's no
reason
right so what you're gonna say demon
souls all you pc dudes get your steam on
baby
what is the reason you gonna pay 400
there's a reason because you're a fan
right
you're a stan right and i feel you but
you can't get one
now that you can't get one and don't
tell me the information about those
dudes having yield problems and all that
stuff
is a lie it's the truth it's the truth
there's a reason why tomorrow they're
saying uh here's the price now tomorrow
you can pre-order
what what a dude when he trying to give
you a dummy what are you trying to do
you trying to get your money and get you
out the door yo yo go ahead go ahead man
the cops
hitting you in the head with the dummy
getting your pre-orders in here we gotta
get the pre-orders because everybody's
gonna pre-order it
so king hold it give me one second
someone literally just posted
the big launch titles i want your
response to this he got diva sews
destruction all stars spider-man miles
morale
sackball astro
room that that that's the launch time
jeff keegley breaking stories i'm
hearing retailers may make
inventory available today stay tuned
so they might try to all right so this
is the panic move
oh all that you hearing because they was
watching people leave the show they was
looking at the words they seen what's
trending
and they did the panic
so we could literally just be buried
in an instant oh oh oh oh hold on
randolph dawg just dropped
something on me uh with playstation blog
let me translate hold on
google yeah i'm hitting google translate
myself yeah it's going to all right
play65 is going to be released on
thursday november 12th
okay digital edition suggested we got
the price today's a special day
we just announced the video it's only
two more okay playstation's available
two miles okay we got that
today we're first announced following
new titles to be released for
playstation five yeah we got that
dell mcra they were not spoiled miranda
i'm trying to look for any
specific thing well let me get up out of
here and finish this okay yo
rand tell me what i'm supposed to be
looking for in this blog oh it just has
it has the launch game list in the
middle
just all the games it's launched five
nights at freddy's is a launch game oh
these are the launch so it's astro play
room demon souls
destruction old stars miles morales
ultimate edition and ribbits ribbits big
adventure okay
yeah anyway none of that
and all you dudes yo sony went shopping
so what was in a shopping cart five
nights with freddy
like wait you win that is a pretty fun
game
oh go ahead king you you went and got
devil may cry special edition something
that just fell out of game pass
that you just picked up off the floor
like yo i'm really sick and tired oh
for
you guys want to see my title where i'm
about to be does that mean god of war is
coming to ps4 yes
that's dlc all of that is dlc there's no
reason to own a ps4 let me hit you with
this and real talk you know i'm gonna
give you your bars back because you
wanted something
they were so adamant about generations
why the pivot i don't think that box
exists
i'ma tell you this i'm gonna tell you
this i really
i really don't i really don't for the
simple fees
one we didn't see one right
the yield problems is it must be real
it must be super unstable in a fashion
that you're going to go to your old box
that
this the joint that you know is
dependable
because it's like yo what this is a
major pivot like they stood
on this square literally just hit
twitter that just hit twitter
it pushes the boundaries we we don't so
the only way you go
back on something i hate to speculate
like that but
wha what reason would you do this about
phase forte right right what what reason
i'm scared to tell you dudes don't
pre-order them all
just hold on dizzy literally just put on
twitter that ssd
oh yeah i forgot about that right that
whole look man that just means that
ratchet and clank is probably gonna end
up working on the ps4 too
i forgot well i didn't see anything
different anyway um yeah
i'm sorry i'm interrupted but we just
get breaking news after breaking news
there's no breaking news you just
you just telling me the show that we
watch is more garbage than we thought
you just literally telling me the show
that you were seeing was not the show
that you saw like
you just don king me
i'm like y'all think i i hate
playstation
wow no i told you those are not the same
people
they are franchisee
they literally just got the license to
put the sony name on the top and it's
different workers inside
and wow workers make
workers make the company when you got a
dreamer
involved sometimes he hit the stars and
he gets it done
but sometimes you overshoot that
juggling thing never sound good to me
the liquid cooling that sounds crazy
but why are you doing it like super fast
ssd
that's incredible but why are you doing
it we just got
ssd debunked now because we we're having
all this stuff that was
supposedly everything else is being done
on a playstation 4 pro
it's listen guys i i i don't want to
tell you
you you going to spend your money how
you going to spend it
i'm going to literally purchase as many
as i can to put them
on ebay to get as many as you
fools that i can get my brother reserved
one i'm gonna have my mom reserve one
anytime you see the reserve say 3 000
for one with no extra nothing
that's what you mean so k k what's if i
can get you a couple up here
if you could we gonna split them
i'm telling you what's happening
profitable
i cover all shipping and everything
listen they're gonna get th
and they're gonna get the you gonna know
it's me because my
business card is gonna be in the box so
anytime you want to do more business of
this nature of this video you know
who to get in contact with and i will
pick up your call
expediently oh my god okay all right
shout out they got some chats for you
was truly king to find out sony pr here
king where would you like gymnastics
shipped
oh no jenna's working for phil
dominus maximus aurelia and spencer and
i told you
somebody said to me somebody said to me
and i'm not gonna shout them out but
somebody said to me
you're gonna give him a really is
already king that's me
and i don't like to bring up old yeah
i said nothing sony is doing is
predicating
on my man's name let's let's take a
moment to just
to just what that everything king has
said that has come to fruition
what type of bizarro world is this
king break their legs and bury them in
the sea don't give it back to them
um smitty schmidt sony scrambling like
roaches with the lights on
um this is going on boogeyman
sony has done nothing to get my dollar
this next gen wow that's crazy pixel bit
geez
let's get some let's oh sorry we gotta
get a super chat brother exclusives are
missing like carmen san diego
wow oh wow they're going in hold
on um oh it's it's it's it's rough right
now bro
it's crazy all right yeah pixel pg i got
data every podcast shout out to me about
to be lit
guys shout out to shout out to luca on
twitter saying all of those bots who had
an epiphany
and saw the blue light and switched over
to playstation switched too late
oh dana rose two dollar super chat that
playstation 4
in store base is too big not to you know
look i i want to just point out
everybody in that chat
everybody in that chat that those
members those those realm
citizens put a knees in there
represented sony's knees because they
lost all of them they lost every single
one of them there's an
army of the the sony executives in that
chat i want to
i want one that's your pure message i
want one for each
one sir you're doing a fantastic job let
your pure messy show
i got i got to link you in this [ __ ] all
right let's send it to me whatever
you're gonna say look
at the future
oh they got me they got something else
on me you guys see it
oh look justin justin russell 2 super
chat no reason to buy playstation 5 it's
in the bushes
squirrelly dan the first generation of
playstation 5's are just ps4s and ps5
cases with an ssd
that's why they give it to you mariano
pumper
fi is the ps4 versions holding next
gen back wow they feel that's all right
that's that's what i want to hear the
chat this is like the revenge of
of yeah microsoft at least microsoft
said that they're only doing it for two
years it looked like sony going a little
further out
2023 yo macho eva macho coming around
he said playstation is awesome xbox type
energy
oh no no no no not oh look here we go
okay
they can't get they can't get credit for
copying oh my god
h five dollars bruh all the knees all
right king finish your ball i'm sorry
it's just so many breaking news i'm
basically done i told you
okay it was worse than i thought yeah it
was absolutely
worse and that trailer with god of war
okay so so
i've been beating the head long time ago
in my dms with that god of war trailer
right but it was like they told me it
was something totally different
um and i said okay and so i said it was
supposed to be another show
and it was like oh they purposely held
stuff back and he they did this
and i'm like i'm never saying anything
again because you're stupid
i heard it was supposed to be um at the
end of the show i didn't believe it and
i was like whatever
we know it's coming it's part of whole
ips this is like saying halo twitter is
on fire right
now you know so we know this stuff is
coming
what we wanted to know what was the
reason to purchase this playstation 5.
they stood on a square so hard and said
miles morales is
only on playstation miles morales is not
dlc
miles morales can only be done this way
miles morales can only
playstation 5 playstation 5 playstation
5. the ssd
the distance this and the power and the
fidelity the raytracing
brother all that is out the window
when you make the game available on the
old system
it's cap it's kind of let's just call it
let's just not even be us it's cap
no this is lion it's lying and and i
can't
listen like i've been defending them for
a while for that
and i can't like i'm not listening it
makes business sense right
we understand the base is bigger based
on playstation 4
right but here's my issue and i've had
this conversation with you king and
the [ __ ] ever okay i just want to say
one thing
oh phil y'all get mad with phil tell the
truth
you'll really get upset at him
i want y'all to get mad that sony is
lying it's lying
we go i'm what it is i want
those people say i'm not going to give
you energy i'm not going i'm not going
to give your name
life right but it's four of you
i'm cool with two of you yeah the other
two can go to hell
but i want y'all to really just stand up
and tell the truth yeah shame the devil
nothing but the name and that's the
difference always say look you can rep
whatever side you rep
always being messy where's the dudes
that said sony police's generation yeah
let's just say like all the guys that
rep aside
all we're saying is when they do
something that is contradictory or are
not
forthcoming you have to call them out
it's the same thing with us we're like
yo
xbox that ain't it you know what i'm
saying with x with such a halo infinite
or whatever
we'll say what we got to say but i just
that's why i'm angry is that
we are literally seeing messaging
not told on the day on the screen during
the show
we gotta go find out that stuff is on
ps4 we gotta
find out that you gotta hold these
companies the same way you tell a
certain base
to hold them accountable you gotta do to
say just because it's your favorite
you're not absolved from that and that's
the thing i hate about this fanboy stuff
because at the end of the day it's like
bro so many people will watch that
and think oh it's only playstation 5
only right
it's only this and and that's the
problem that gets me upset and it's just
like look
i get it just be transparent and tell
people what it is that's all
but now we're gonna have this situation
and the question like we said
is why why have you now completely
pivoted on a generation's talk
you know why have you now almost pivoted
on the pc
stuff coming to pc's talk right that was
the other thing
so again use your eyes the people who
are on that side or whatever just use
your eyes
in that regard and be honest that's all
i'm saying
you know what i'm saying but listen
sorry what brand says something that
y'all said to chad yeah like fourteen
guys no no no go ahead no i was just
gonna say this just
you know once once the financial officer
becomes the ceo of the whole freaking
company
money talks and it just comes down to
the fact that
he ain't stupid he knows that yeah we do
value our ip but just because your ip is
in other places doesn't mean that your
ip is less value
and what i was told people arguing me on
twitter when i put up a poll
when um remember when grounded was
leading steam and you know um
four microsoft exclusives are on top ten
in steam
it was like uh massive collection flight
simulator
grounded cfds i was just like wow that's
really cool do you think
all i asked was like do you think how
quickly do you think sony will try to
adopt a similar chat
these people came after me as if i said
something like
how they don't they're the leaders they
don't follow they're not and i'm just
like bro
it's steam money like why would they not
think about it and then when they put
horizon over there
right it cracked the top five or
whatever it was right so again it's just
this um
i just hate this emotional tie
where people are just so irrational
right
because of their feelings about this
this this box
they just cannot fake this is still
business this is still
money this is what these companies are
out to do they don't care about your
feelings
that's what this is
are you implying that these fools are
duped that they think they love them yo
and you know that that's one of the
things that you cannot take away
from from microsoft like you know
they've they've been trained transparent
this whole time so like exactly
halo's coming to both we get it you guys
want a next-gen experience we're not
gonna lie like
do you remember a certain group
see because it's throwing the xbox one
this is a part you know about the health
of sony oh
no no remember the whole holding back
the whole
we would get bible verses about holding
back
and now we're hearing all these games
are doing the same thing
like let's keep the energy that that's
what got me so mad i normally don't
engage in this nonsense but it's just
that at the end of the day
you see these people on it on the
timeline so emotional
trying to ridicule another base why they
shouldn't be excited about something
right and then everyone's armchair dev
now
their group's doing it i want to know
what what the energy is now
you know you let me tell you something
these people unfortunately
microsoft has set us up for this over
the course of the last couple of years
like this is something that we had to
deal with
ever since play anywhere became a thing
and everybody was like oh all your games
are on pc and your games are going back
and forth
oh the price of the games is out seventy
dollars
for everything everything you know what
the craziest part about this in the long
run is
is the the the xbox fan base
they they slowly rolled them through
through the grinder
they slowly railed them and now you know
we come out the other side
we understand what's going on we know
what's going on we we expect it at this
point but it's like
sony is being hit by a spirit bomb
they're being hit by kamehameha
it's like they're being surrounded well
you shot out like like anger man said go
look at j main thing where he's when
they talked about um demon souls he was
super excited ps5 only and then as
he saw pc he was like never mind because
it's like you're like how many people
like this is the difference between xbox
and playstation to me it is not a bad
thing because you should get excited
for a platform that you truly enjoy
being absolutely
like outside of kids move on xbox
there's really
nobody else that i see get super amped
up for what stuff that xbox does like
physically on the screen you see kid's
move get animated
for stuff like that he's a true xbox fan
i saw so many people going live with
this stream
looking like they just got through doing
a jumping jack before the show even
started
it's like they got so amped up because
they are so invested in what michael and
sony is doing
it's like now they're being hit by
something that they thought sony would
never do and that's where the again
that's where the blind yes that's what
the tribalism and the blind loyalty
when you don't when you're not rational
right and now
this this rocks your world right for a
person who's
who's a tribalist like oh my god they
betray how dare they
like they that that's where the
non-transparency is going to hurt
it's going to hurt now you know what i'm
saying let me read these super checks
it's great six slash shout out to our
super chat
that's my brother man that's my um oled
brother um where
where is christopher hart someone called
swat to check y'all messi
oh damn i missed him a lot are you about
to close out um no because we got super
chats that we got
okay i just want to ask a question to
the chat really quick first off let's
put in there one to ten what's your
rating for this event
yeah uh just the event itself don't take
all the information we got out of it i
want you know your rating on the event
itself
and second off tell me what podcasts you
guys are watching this week
put that in the chat too man toby those
party guys
i literally put on twitter i said i'm
watching every podcast this weekend i
don't care how whack they are i'm
watching them all
you'll be investing if i pay back his
payback i know what you want drunken
ninja turtles
am i wrong does xbox have next
generation only exclusives interesting
one bad mother fought out of a chat i
want the same energy
suddenly an entire legion of plastic
warriors
taking jim ryan's dance class they gotta
improve those dares because randolph
thought
what a day of dano 5 only possible on
the playstation 4. yeah
you right you're right dan rodriguez
season gamers minnie smith 5
super chat playstation 5 bad boys got
baptized and now they see the like
the book of x the k asante
two dollar super chat did y'all all see
playstation five games or seventy
dollars
game pass ftw yo
it's gonna hit a lot of people it's
gonna hit a lot of people absolutely
right um let's see we got somebody
just breathe all this yo element appeal
find out
so how cheap is can i get that ps4 when
the series x comes out oh my god
cat daddy two dollar super chat yes
final fantasy 16
pc uh to pc demon souls to pc 10 out of
10 show
y'all used to cat daddy with his pc
messiness
savage smitty smith follow super chat
sony
gave the playstation fans boys the whop
and then took it away
and that's why they emotionally oh my
god let me take over
we got a five dollar super chat from
jonathan b looks like horizon
forbidden west is coming to the ps4 you
know what jonathan b you might be on to
something
and then then we got a um i'm being way
too messy but it's okay
we got a 35 a z-a-r i don't know what
currency is microsoft is always
years ahead of people give them a crap
for it they are not a trained dollar
company for nothing
i appreciate it someone else pronounced
his name i'm not butchering that man's
name
this is someone else i don't know
muhammad diallo
or i don't know man i'm sorry man i
tried i tried
we got a two dollar superstar yeah
muhammad diallo from pixel bit
g where is the backwards compatible they
they showed you something they showed
you
some of the select listed games brother
that's my guy finals of a chat shout out
to the lords love y'all about to rewind
the podcast to catch the show everybody
be
busy bro that's what's up we got five
dollars super chat from boogie man every
exclusive on the ps5 i want is timed and
going to xbox series x no reason to bet
on that pony
no let me get the wahzo game he's saying
somebody dropping balls
as a person who's buying both salute i
love going on twitter and watching the
fanboys duke it out what can i say
i love watching the world burn you we
got a two dollar super chat from
jonathan b no horizon 2 is confirmed for
ps4
i know man i'm sorry if i said horizon
we got a five dollar shipping drive from
shrimp kingdom phyllis singh
thanks to jim ryan workout plan i'm the
envy of all my friends
randolph davian messi playstation has
two next-gen exclusives yeah that was
the talk
hairy balls with the finale auto fantasy
16 of diva souls
it's console exclusive for a limited
time but available on pc
gotta go check the fine print oh boy we
got a two dollar super chat from
john i'm not trying to pronounce that
miles horizon sac boy my holiday is lit
on ps4
randolph though where is chris
everybody's asking for christopher hart
yeah he he was on that let me see if
he's in there get that next one
yes glader five pounds of a chat i never
do super chats
but i'm a cheap as hell but the amount
of needs that y'all
are on the way to the lords those yeah
those cops love you money not you a
sodium
he's a sony fan saying that yo let's get
some more boxes and he's in that chat
man every member i want
boxes of the knees sick let's say a
suicide alert look
it's not suicide alert if you're a gamer
right if you're a gamer
and you know the hardest camping outside
gamestop right in the premier league
but for some people this is a dark day
for some people
this is man the web is black i saw all
these little
the shows talking all the sony crap
all you little fake tech heads out here
somebody's gonna come in and they're
going to do
crazy things so when he's going to ah
look i finished my ball for me i was
yeah definitely surprised this this show
took me off they started off
bang bang bang bang bang and then it's
like forte it's like eggman said it for
me it
as the layers started to peel off and
you started to get more information
outside of the show
then it started to hit different and you
know what i mean you know what's sad
that they would have been more upfront
and open with stuff they wouldn't get
hit this hard
like i still thought the game's solid
it's just like i said but when you
when you don't tell anybody that this is
coming to ps4 shout out to the front
alerts going by right now
they don't tell people that it's ps4 and
then that hit
you know it's gonna it's gonna hit
different then the pc thing is gonna hit
different you know what i'm saying
for me of course i'm a gamer i'm picking
it up i'm gonna do my comparisons with
the multi-platforms i'm gonna do my
comparisons with that
ssd and all that stuff but you need to
do your comparisons with
i can't hear the jefferson's plane in
the background
what you know about that show what you
know about singing it with the right
cadence i don't i do not
like this cadence that you actually have
on my tv show
all right we we we we're going to act
like you guys that's before your era bro
that's before
i'll be bright like you our friendship
got deep down
he watched movie land stop playing
but he's sucking with the right thing is
that is that is that the one where it
was like what you talking about what was
that was that
yeah that was different strokes but you
you offered that you didn't
watch that too uh from the living flame
they had to put their games on the ps4
when they knew they had the shortage
ssd advantages won't apply to the end of
this gin
throw the frauds out let's get some
fraud alerts in for uh
white man let's go i gotta go i gotta go
we go roll up soon do that we just keep
getting the super super
chat yeah yeah stay tuned with the six
five the ps4 turn around for some of the
games
add more fuel to the rumor of the
shortages and then yeah look man this is
it so at the end of the day
you know getting it um
make sure i i i still you know i gotta
rewatch it too i gotta be like
i'm i'm i don't gotta re-watch i'm
conflicted with a lot of things i
i wanna get my thoughts correct by
rewatching it but um
yeah but for some people you know if
this is not gonna go well for
for for warriors for guys who've been on
the front line
who's been preaching you know fighting
that console
yeah there's guys that's been preaching
design and guys has been preaching
holding back and guys has been preaching
exclusives and
a company would never do this get ready
this is the first thing i wanted to
thank man you
we had 560 oh yeah yeah like you guys
coming here first off
we way too late than we should have you
guys are being given that we almost have
300 likes and i want to appreciate every
single one of you even the people coming
here to hate on us
that is fine you guys can get that too
you know i appreciate everyone
put some logos in that chat we got to
the the day that place they should drop
the ball put some logos in that chat we
gotta remember this day macho broker
your playstation 4 games so pc please
yeah let's see
that chat squirrel just replaced it when
god of war 2 was on the playstation 4
pro
you guys are going to really be upset
please take your files coming to please
hit ps4 to make up for money lost on
playstation 5
price brownie boom two dollars what the
heck was that
oh my god you just must have been
watching it but uh yeah man i'll edit
this out with y'all for today
i'll give you the final bars man let's
get up out of here man cause this is
this is a funny day
yeah we went so long i'm not even gonna
be able to make a video yes
uh forte you say that bro yeah i'll let
you i'll let you end it brother cause i
know you gotta like
oh wait right hold on red giving you
know rand got something for us right now
playstation said there are no plans in
making cross-generation titles
after goes to sushima don't expect any
first party titles to make its way to
the playstation 4.
so they're kind of like in a transition
period right no i i think this is
probably old
oh he's bringing up the oh oh he brings
up let me see
oh red i got you i got you brother i got
you i don't see when the date of this
one yeah let's get the date on that
though let's get the date let's see 14
gaming by choice get that game of my
choice while i'm doing this research
okay i got it let's see so we got to
find out super chat from gamer by choice
i hate that they didn't dislike
backwards discuss backwards
compatibility
well enough to know what it is available
day one i think they showed you what's
available
right i think rand is right because i'm
looking at comments
subscribe to get those games yeah yeah
you gotta subscribe to the other
servers yeah playstation boss says there
are no plans to make cross generate this
is in may y'all
this jim ryan spoke on the company's
philosophy saying we always had said we
believe in generations
we believe that when you go to all the
trouble of creating a next-gen console
that it should include feet yo this is
straight line yeah this is like midnight
may 29th yeah may 29th that yo ran isn't
it bad but
right right right right be having this
you haven't only had like
you guys he's got a microsoft word
document he just got a bunch of links in
there just for writing
29th brother did we get this uh we got a
two dollar super chat from army veteran
that was a tcl
show no dude as the tco ambassador that
is not what we call
tcl all right that is like one of those
big
box ones that's back in the day that's
what events show that's that's this
listen
that's a projector show that's what that
is this is lying
this is just called it's lying and it's
dance moves king's edge he was dancing
baby i told you
he came out he did it he did it nice i
loved it he did it
he was looking like fred astaire out
there and then he came up and
owned his show at the end you saw him he
came out and let you know
this is me right this is how y'all gonna
get it done for y'all from now on
no more sean lady no more theatrics
every time i go on twitter
plus notification every single time i go
on twitter i got twitter
it literally it literally says it will
not
wow playstation but says there are no
plans it literally says
that's the title playstation boss says
oh slo-mo that's lomo he just put on
twitter
i quote i might just save the money i
was going to spend on that ps5 and get a
30 80 instead of a 30. oh we had slow-mo
talking about that the other day i was
like slow-mo
i said slow-mo i was like bro i might
not get this ps5 bro i might have to
just save that money and put it towards
that 30 80.
hold on y'all got to see it this is the
title y'all like let
me look really like playstation 5 boss
says there's no plans
may 29th yeah man wow interesting
so so uh uh fc violet just tagged
optimus code and bradford so you guys
good man just checking on you
just checking on y'all look man so yeah
my forte ended up man because we gotta
go alright y'all ended up i had to get
off my computer because my daughter had
some stuff for school school bro so
no but man i would keep the same energy
like and this thing i expect everybody
to keep the same energy that they always
have
i'm still getting the playstation 5. i
just don't have no reason
to buy it day one the whole reason i
want it is because
yes god of war might come to ps to ps4
it may do that but if it does
the reason i'm buying that ps5 is
because i want to have the best version
of god of war i could possibly have
but i don't have to buy that thing day
one the fact that all of these games
are coming to the playstation 4 as of
right now
i just want to make sure that everybody
out here understands that
we people that's been saying this on
xbox same dog it's good for gamers
everybody gets a chance to play these
games
right you know they're not you know it's
not behind a 500
pay wall like people have been saying
and stuff dude
as of right now this is a reckoning for
everybody that feels like these
corporations are out for you
yeah they ain't out for you they offer
they always gonna make them the most
money
and then spiderman being on multiple
platforms is gonna make them more money
that's what they're gonna do preach
trust me no you're fact
and the thing is this is ps4 just
confirmed their game ps5 game is gonna
be 70.
oh yeah we just heard that they also ps5
games are going to be they just
confirmed ps5 games would be
so why would you buy a mouse for ten
dollars more
literally you just gonna spend 570
dollars plus that you're gonna spend six
hundred dollars to play miles where you
could just
buy it or dlc for probably 30 bucks on
your playstation
i can't wait macho i disagree he's
saying that they didn't say
macho is saying he didn't say that
they're any there aren't any plans for
cross gen cog
they're doing a glitch he said um it's
implied because of the quote
so then okay
at the end of the day like i said um
this is why we all like i said we always
say
question ask when you don't have enough
information
question ask and there's there was a
base that was saying
no don't question it's definitely this
it's definitely that it's definitely
this it's definitely that and i'm like
there's no information that supports
that
i'm just asking and that that group got
attacked
and now we're finding out information
otherwise did we get that two dollar
supercharger please
jim ryan still it's still not being
truthful
and that that's at the bottom line it's
not being truthful i don't care how you
spin it
it's not being honest and that's just
the truth so
did we get that two dollars please get
it please get it we got a two dollar
super trip from smitty smith jim ryan
doing the harlem shake
yeah oh that's it y'all y'all know what
it is
um i definitely don't want to miss this
sunday man
people be interesting everybody look man
thanks for rocking out though 522 in the
chat
great great great turnout super chats
with love i know i loved king and his
bag
you know what i'm saying hold on shout
out to oh shout out chief tommy great
show love would like to give a big shout
out to cog for making live reaction
balance with all these xbox lovers
look i just try to tell the truth as
best i can bro but this is gonna
this is an interesting day it's gonna be
a trip today
like y'all enjoy man we're gonna get out
here we're gonna hit him with the giant
we're gonna hit him with the last promo
yeah last promo all right no doubt john
one
hi i'm lord king david of iron lords
podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able
to be part of that giveaway there's
two ways to get your name
thrown in the hat for the raffle
one become a member of the realm
that's hit that join button hit that joy
button you hit that join button down at
the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in
our community and this community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
that's the who did that for you
sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man have a great